Hey there, Shankar here. We're dropping this episode on September 22nd, 2025. That's 10 years to the day since we first launched Hidden Brain into the world. Welcome to the first episode of the Hidden Brain podcast. I'm Shankar Vedantham. A lot has changed since we started this podcast. But for us, one thing remains steadfast. Week in and week out, we love making this show for you.
大家好，我是香卡。我们将在2025年9月22日发布这期节目。正好是我们首次将“隐藏的大脑”推向世界十周年的日子。欢迎收听“隐藏的大脑”播客的第一期节目。我是香卡·维丹坦。自从我们开办这个播客以来，发生了很多变化。但对我们来说，有一件事始终坚定不移。日复一日，年复一年，我们都热爱为你制作这档节目。
It's been our calling. So today, we mark this anniversary with an episode about just that, callings and how finding one can change our lives. If you've been listening to Hidden Brain for many years, please come to my live tour. I'll be in Baltimore on October 11th, in Washington, D.C. on October 12th, and in Los Angeles on November 22nd.
这是我们的天职。因此，今天我们用一期专门探讨天职以及找到天职如何改变我们生活的节目来庆祝这个周年纪念。如果你收听“隐藏的大脑”已经很多年了，请来参加我的现场巡演。我将于10月11日去巴尔的摩，10月12日去华盛顿特区，以及11月22日去洛杉矶。
More dates are coming in 2026. I'll be sharing seven key insights from the first decade of the show. For more information and tickets, go to hiddenbrain.org slash tour. Again, that's hiddenbrain.org slash tour. Hope to see you there, and here's today's show. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In 2005, an intense man with a receding hairline and glasses stood before thousands of young graduates in Palo Alto,
2026年还会有更多场次。我将分享节目开播第一个十年的七大核心见解。欲了解更多信息并购票，请访问 hiddenbrain.org 斜杠 tour。再说一遍，是 hiddenbrain.org 斜杠 tour。希望能在那里见到你，以下是今天的节目。这里是“隐藏的大脑”。我是香卡·维丹坦。2005年，在帕洛阿尔托，
California. He wore dark robes with a hood of Cardinal Red. Truth be told, he joked, I never graduated from college, and this is the closest I've ever gotten to a college graduation. The speech that Steve Jobs gave at Stanford University's commencement that year didn't just transfix his audience. It would transfix countless other audiences in the years to come. His central message was simple. As he put it, your time is limited. Don't waste it, living someone else's life. I'm convinced that the only thing that kept me going
加利福尼亚州，一位神情坚毅、发际线后移并戴着眼镜的男士站在数千名年轻毕业生面前。他穿着黑色长袍，戴着红衣主教红的风帽。说实话，他开玩笑说，我从未从大学毕业，这是我离大学毕业最近的一次。史蒂夫·乔布斯当年在斯坦福大学毕业典礼上的演讲不仅吸引了在场的观众。在未来的岁月里，它还将吸引无数其他观众。他的核心信息很简单。正如他所说，你的时间是有限的。不要浪费它，去过别人的生活。我确信，唯一能让我坚持下去的
was that I loved what I did. You've got to find what you love. And that is as true for work as it is for your lovers. Finding a vocation, the inventor and entrepreneur said, was no less important than finding a soulmate. As with all matters of the heart, you'll know when you find it. And like any great relationship, it just gets better and better as the years roll on.
原因，就是我热爱我所做的事情。你必须找到你所爱的东西。工作如此，你的爱人也同样如此。这位发明家兼企业家说，寻找职业并不比寻找灵魂伴侣逊色。正如所有关于内心的事务一样，当你找到它时，你就会知道。就像任何伟大的恋情一样，随着岁月流逝，它会变得越来越好。
And what if you hadn't found something you loved? What if the work you did paid the bills but didn't complete you? The iconoclastic leader of Apple Inc. had very definite advice for the recent graduates. Your work is going to fill a large part of your life and the only way to be truly satisfied is to do what you believe is great work.
如果你还没有找到你热爱的东西呢？如果你所做的工作能维持生计，却无法让你感到圆满呢？这位苹果公司标新立异的领袖对应届毕业生提出了非常明确的建议。你的工作将占据你生活很大的一部分，唯一真正满足的方法就是去做你认为伟大的工作。
And the only way to do great work is to love what you do. If you haven't found it yet, keep looking and don't settle. The idea of being driven by a calling goes back centuries. It was the language used to describe religious people who were called to the priesthood, to a life of service and prayer. You were called, in effect, by God.
而做伟大工作的唯一方法，就是热爱你的工作。如果你还没有找到，继续寻找，不要将就。被天职驱动的想法可以追溯到几个世纪前。这是用来描述宗教人士的语言，他们被召唤去担任神职，过一种服务和祈祷的生活。实际上，你是被上帝召唤的。
Today, millions of people in secular professions yearn to be similarly galvanized by their work. This week on Hidden Brain, the immense power and the downsides of pursuing a calling. Have you ever looked up from your work in the middle of the day and asked yourself, is this all there is? Am I really doing what I was meant to do? What are the thoughts and images that go through your mind at times like this? Who do you compare yourself to? What do you wish you were doing instead? At Babson College, Jennifer Toasty Carras studies how we find meaning in work and ways we can derive more satisfaction and purpose in our professional lives.
今天，世俗职业中的数百万人都渴望在工作中同样受到这种激励。本周的“隐藏的大脑”，我们将探讨追求天职的巨大力量及其消极面。你是否曾在白天的某个时刻从工作中抬起头问自己，生活难道就只有这些吗？我真的在做我注定要做的事情吗？在这种时候，有哪些想法和画面掠过你的脑海？你把你自己和谁作比较？你希望自己换作在做什么？在巴布森学院，詹妮弗·托斯蒂·卡拉斯研究我们在工作中如何寻找意义，以及如何在职业生活中获得更多满足感和目标感的方法。
Jennifer Toasty Kerris, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much, Unker. Jen, I want to start with a story of a stockbroker in the 19th century. What do we know about Paul Gougain's life as a middle-class breadwinner in 19th century Paris? Yeah, so before he was the celebrated world-renowned artist that we know today, Paul Gagant was a work-a-day stiff. he was a very reluctant stock trader. He hated this job, which required him to sort of, you know, dress up, put in long
詹妮弗·托斯蒂·卡里斯，欢迎来到“隐藏的大脑”。非常感谢你，香卡。珍，我想从一个19世纪股票经纪人的故事开始。关于保罗·高更作为19世纪巴黎中产阶级顶梁柱的生活，我们知道些什么？是的，所以在成为我们今天所知的那位名扬四海、享誉全球的艺术家之前，保罗·高更只是一个普通的上班族。他是一个非常勉强的股票交易员。他讨厌这份工作，这份工作要求他某种程度上，你知道，盛装打扮，在办公室里投入漫长的时间。
hours in the office. And he had this sort of, let's call it, a side pursuit, maybe not quite a side hustle, but he certainly had this interest outside of work, which was art and both making art and collecting art. Perhaps you know someone like this, whose days are filled with work they detest. Perhaps you feel this way yourself and wonder how your life could have turned out differently. In 1882, the stock market crashed
他还有一种，我们称之为副业的东西，也许还算不上真正的副业，但他确实在工作之余有这种兴趣，那就是艺术，包括创作艺术和收藏艺术。也许你认识这样的人，他们的日子被他们痛恨的工作填满。也许你自己也有这种感觉，并想过你的人生本可以有怎样不同的结局。1882年，股市崩盘，
and Paul Gorgand lost his day job. He started to look for work that would pay the bills. He was in a situation that so many people do find themselves where essentially to try to make a living, to try to support your family. I mean, truly in a subsistence, way, he was casting about for any job he could find. Even as he was struggling to make ends meet, Paul Gagand kept returning to his passion.
保罗·高更失去了日常工作。他开始寻找能维持生计的工作。他处于一种许多人都会发现自己身处的境地，基本上是为了谋生，为了养家糊口。我的意思是，在绝对维持生存的方式下，他四处搜寻任何能找到的工作。尽管他一直在艰难维持生计，保罗·高更却不断回归他的激情。
Art was his refuge, his calling. Would he ever be happy if he kept ignoring it? This is part of the power of this story in the sense of, what if then, to escape this drudgery, I made a radical break. sort of if I'm not fulfilled here, might I be better fulfilled or more fulfilled elsewhere, and in a way that's a lot closer to my passions? Paul Gogh took a move that a lot of us wouldn't. So after trying various attempts to move and new cities, he left everything, truly
艺术是他的避难所，他的天职。如果他继续忽视它，他会快乐吗？这就是这个故事力量的一部分，也就是说，如果为了逃离这种枯燥的生活，我做了一个彻底的决裂，会怎么样呢？如果我在这里没有得到成就感，我在其他地方会不会得到更好的成就感或更多的成就感，并且这种方式更接近我的激情？保罗·高更采取了许多人不会采取的行动。因此，在多次尝试搬迁到新城市之后，他抛弃了一切，真的
chucked it all, upended his life. and moved to Tahiti and pursued his art full-time. Paul Goggan's life after he moved to Tahiti has been the subject of a great deal of scrutiny among modern biographers and art historians. In Tahiti, then a French colony, he lived for years with a 13-year-old girl. He impregnated a 14-year-old.
把一切都抛在脑后，颠覆了自己的生活，搬到了大溪地，全职追求他的艺术。保罗·高更移居大溪地后的生活一直是现代传记作家和艺术史学家大量审视的主题。在大溪地这个当时的法国殖民地，他和一名13岁的女孩生活了多年。他使一名14岁的女孩怀孕。
Such behavior would be both illegal and disturbing to people in many parts of the world today. But in the 19th century, the legal age for sexual consent in France and French colonies was 13. When Paul Gorgand died in 1903, he was still relatively unknown. Jennifer says that changed after his death.
这种行为在当今世界的许多地方既违法又令人不安。但在19世纪，法国及法国殖民地的法定性承诺年龄是13岁。1903年保罗·高更去世时，他仍然相对默默无闻。詹妮弗说，这在他死后发生了变化。
So we know now posthumously, he was extremely successful. And again, he's one of those names that if you can name a few painters, famous painters. He's likely one of them. So we remember Paul Goggan today not for his acumen as a stockbroker or his skill as a sales rep, but for his art. And his paintings, of course, hang in the world's preeminent museums today. Do you think, at least in death, he would say that his gamble paid off?
所以我们现在知道，在他死后，他获得了极大的成功。再说一次，如果你能说出几位画家里有谁，著名的画家，他很可能是其中之一。所以我们今天纪念保罗·高更，不是因为他作为股票经纪人的敏锐度或作为销售代表的技能，而是因为他的艺术。当然，他的画作今天悬挂在世界最卓越的博物馆里。你认为，至少在死后，他会说他的这场豪赌得到了回报吗？
It would be hard not to say that, again, given the level of fame, notoriety, perhaps infamy, but, you know, that he's that he's enjoyed. So Paul Gogh was so influential, not only on his peers. So people like Vincent Van Gogh, but on, you know, generations of artists to come, not least of which was Pablo Picasso. So art historians have drawn a direct line from the oceanic iconography and styling. You know, it's not completely naturalistic. It's somewhat abstract representation of form in Goghans, Tahitian figures, and the work of Picasso and Cubism.
鉴于他所享有的名气、声誉，也许是恶名，但你知道，鉴于他所享受的一切，很难不这么说。所以保罗·高更能产生如此深远的影响，不仅对他的同龄人，比如文森特·梵高，而且对后来的几代艺术家，其中最著名的就是巴勃罗·毕加索。因此，艺术史学家在海洋图像和风格之间画出了一条直接的线。你知道，它并不完全是自然主义的。在某种程度上，它是高更大溪地人物中形式的抽象表现，以及毕加索和立体主义的作品。
So in terms of his impact on art today as we know it, it's been massive. And therefore, it's very hard to look and say that this gamble didn't pay off. In fact, absent this huge risk to chuck it all. and moved to Tahiti, we would not have the art that I love going to the MFA in Boston and looking at this giant, famous, maybe one of the most iconic Gogan paintings, which hangs proudly there, and we would not have this beautiful art that everyone appreciates and loves to look at. I want to talk about another person who had a giant effect as a result.
因此，就他对我们今天所知的艺术的影响而言，它是巨大的。因此，很难看着并说这场豪赌没有得到回报。事实上，如果不冒着抛弃一切并搬到大溪地的巨大风险，我们就不会拥有这些艺术，我喜欢去波士顿美术馆看着这幅巨大的、著名的、也许最具代表性的高更画作，它自豪地悬挂在那里，我们就不会拥有这幅每个人都欣赏和喜爱的美丽艺术。我想谈谈另一位因为她的工作而产生了巨大影响，并同样影响了许多后来者的人。这位是科学家玛丽·居里。她是一位以对工作极其执着而闻名的物理学家。詹妮弗，谈谈她所产生的影响吧。
of her work and also influenced a number of people who came after her. This is the scientist Murray Curie. She was a physicist who was famously devoted to her work. Talk about the impact she had, Jennifer. Her impact today is widely felt in the use of radiology and medicine. She's completely changed the way we think about radioactivity, evident in so many domains of modern life. Yet, on top of that, perhaps in a way that we wouldn't say Gogh was, Marie Curie was a groundbreaker. So she was the first woman to win a Nobel Prize. She was not only that, the first person to win a Nobel Prize twice and in separate disciplines. So in physics and in chemistry. Similarly, her sort of all or nothing, all in commitment to doing the science, I think really
她今天的影响在放射学和医学的应用中广受感知。她彻底改变了我们对放射性的思考方式，这在现代生活的许多领域中显而易见。然而，除此之外，或许以一种我们不会说高更所具备的方式，玛丽·居里是一位开拓者。她是第一位获得诺贝尔奖的女性。不仅如此，她还是第一位两次获得诺贝尔奖并且是在不同学科领域获奖的人。所以在物理学和化学领域。同样，她那种要么全盘接受要么一无所有、全身心投入科学的承诺，我认为确实使她与众不同。
sets it apart. So this is similarly someone who was somewhat obsessed with her work, put a great deal into it. And for her, it wasn't about, you know, fame or recognition. She famously gave away her Nobel Prize money to students who needed it. But she, you know, she was a towering figure who we recognize today. And it's also clear, Jen, that looking back, we know that she paid an enormous price for her success as a scientist. In fact, many people believe she died as a result of her pursuit of the study of radioactivity. Yeah. And I think that is really the ultimate symbol of us being willing to sacrifice everything for our work is the willingness to potentially die as a result of the work or related to the work that we're doing, whether it's directly from
所以这也是一个对自己的工作有些痴迷、投入了大量心血的人。对她而言，这与名誉或认可无关。众所周知，她把诺贝尔奖金捐给了需要的学生。但她，你知道，是一个我们今天所认可的泰斗级人物。而且很显然，珍，回首过去，我们知道她为自己作为科学家的成功付出了巨大的代价。事实上，许多人认为她死于对放射性研究的追求。是的。我认为这确实是我们愿意为工作牺牲一切的终极象征，那就是愿意因为工作或与工作相关的事情而潜在地死亡，无论是直接来自
the work itself or as a result of not taking care of ourselves because we are doing, we are pursuing work that we love. So as I was preparing for this interview, Jen, I came by a clip from an American pioneer. She was born in poverty in Mississippi to a single mom, but she always felt like she was cut out for great things. I want you to listen to this clip from Oprah Winfrey. Sometimes the calling is right in your own neighborhood. the calling is something that was just a whisper to you.
工作本身，还是由于我们没有照顾好自己，因为我们在做、在追求我们热爱的工作。因此，当我为这次采访做准备时，珍，我偶然看到了一段美国先驱的视频片段。她出生在密西西比州的一个贫困家庭，由单亲妈妈抚养长大，但她总是觉得自己注定要做大事。我希望你听听这段奥普拉·温弗瑞的视频。有时天职就在你自己的社区里。天职就是对你而言仅仅是一种低语的东西。
And when you begin to honor that whisper and to follow that, you end up being the best that you could be. Now, Oprah, of course, went on to become a billionaire. You know, people have begged her to run for president. So we've looked at a painter in the 19th century, a scientist in the 20th century, and a television star in the 21st century. Do you hear common threads in these stories, Jen?
当你开始尊重这种低语并跟随它时，你最终会成为最好的自己。当然，奥普拉后来成为了一名亿万富翁。你知道，人们曾恳求她竞选总统。因此，我们看了一位19世纪的画家，一位20世纪的科学家，以及一位21世纪的电视明星。珍，你在这些故事中听到了共同的线索吗？
So absolutely. I think the common thread here is this notion that work can be a calling. It can be more than just a paycheck. It can be a source of personal fulfillment, of doing great things in the world. And as we talked about, a really deep sense of immersing yourself in the doing of the work, it does show the power, I believe, of viewing one's work as more than if you will, just a job, but as a real possibility to contribute both to yourself and to the world at large. When we come back, the psychology of vocations and how we can all find greater meaning in our work. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. When Steve Jobs spoke at Stanford's commencement in 2005, he told the story of why he dropped out of college. It was pretty scary at the time, he said, but looking back, it was one of the best decisions I was. ever made.
当然。我认为这里的共同线索是这种观念，即工作可以是一种天职。它不仅是一份薪水。它可以是个人成就感的来源，是世界上做伟大事情的来源。正如我们所讨论的，一种真正沉浸在工作过程中的深厚感，它确实展示了我所相信的力量，即把一个人的工作视为不仅仅是一份工作，而是为自己和整个世界做出贡献的真正可能性。稍后我们将回来，探讨职业的心理学以及我们如何在工作中找到更多的意义。你正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”。我是香卡·维丹坦。这里是“隐藏的大脑”。我是香卡·维丹坦。2005年，当史蒂夫·乔布斯在斯坦福大学毕业典礼上演讲时，他讲述了自己为什么要从大学辍学的故事。他说，当时挺吓人的，但回过头来看，这是我做过的最好的决定之一。
Dropping out allowed him to drop in on classes that interested him, rather than classes he was being told to attend. He said, I didn't have a dorm room, so I slept on the floor in friends' rooms. I returned coke bottles for the five-cent deposits to buy food with, and I would walk the seven miles across town every Sunday night to get one good meal a week at the Hari-Krishna Temple. I loved it, and much of what I stumbled into by following my curiosity and intuition turned out to be priceless later on.
辍学让他能够去旁听那些他感兴趣的课程，而不是那些别人告诉他必须要上的课程。他说，我没有宿舍，所以我就睡在朋友房间的地板上。我靠退还可乐瓶来换取五美分的押金买食物，每个星期天晚上，我都要步行七英里穿过全城，去奎师那神庙吃上一顿一周中难得的好饭。我很喜欢，而我通过顺从自己的好奇心和直觉偶然发现的许多东西，后来都被证明是无价之宝。
At Babson College, Jennifer Toastycarus studies the nature and meaning of work. Jen, you say that the notion that we can find meaning and pleasure in work is relatively recent. How recent? The idea of work as a calling goes way, way back to the Protestant Reformation, where the idea was work could be a calling, and specifically that calling was to the ministry, to the clergy, to serve God directly. Now, work as a secular calling started to gain a foothold around the time that we started having knowledge work. So kind of 80s, 90s, where I have a project I can own, I can really
在巴布森学院，詹妮弗·托斯蒂·卡拉斯研究工作的本质和意义。珍，你说我们能在工作中找到意义和快乐的观念是相对较近的事情。有多近？把工作视为天职的想法可以追溯到很久很久以前的新教改革，当时的想法是工作可以是一种天职，具体而言，那种天职是献身于圣职、神职，直接服务上帝。现在，作为世俗天职的工作开始获得立足点，大约在我们开始有知识型工作的时候。大约在80年代、90年代，当时我有一个可以由我掌控的项目，我可以真正
invest myself into. And so therefore, I really feel like it's more than just my job. It's me. I'm actually putting me into it. I would say that the time of this Steve Jobs commencement speech 2005 is right around the time of peak calling. And if you look at Google Ngrams for find your calling or find your passion, it really follows this. We see this like, you know, meandering line, very low, starting to uptick in the early 1980s and then reaching this, you know, kind of insane, asymptotic almost peak in right around the early 2000s. And so, you know, while this idea has deep roots, we don't assume this is a calling from a higher power, but that the experience of the calling is very, very personal, very deep, and very sort of connected to this sense of
投入其中。因此，我真的觉得这不仅仅是我的工作。这就是我。我实际上把我自己投入进去了。我想说，史蒂夫·乔布斯毕业典礼演讲的2005年，正是天职狂热达到顶峰的时期。如果你看一下谷歌图书关于“寻找你的天职”或“寻找你的激情”的词频趋势（Ngrams），它确实符合这一点。我们看到这种蜿蜒的线条，非常低，在20世纪80年代初开始上升，然后在大约2000年代初达到了这种疯狂的、几乎呈渐近线的顶峰。所以，你知道，虽然这个想法有着深厚的根源，但我们并不认为这来自更高力量的天职，而是认为体验天职是非常、非常私人的，非常深刻的，并且与这种感觉紧密相连。
So your own research has explored the effects of having a calling. You've examined the happiness levels of people who have found a calling. Are these people more engaged and satisfied with their work, Jim? Yeah, they are. So I conducted, along with my co-authors, Shasa DeBrough, Hannah Weissman and Danny Heller. We conducted about a 20-year survey, quantitative survey, of results on what it means to experience work as a calling. And we found very strongly that people with strong callings report greater satisfaction with their work and their life and with engagement at work and some behavioral indicators of better performance, lower absenteeism, and these are sort of consistent findings across studies about how and why experiencing work
所以你自己的研究探讨了拥有天职的影响。你考察了找到天职的人的幸福水平。这些人对他们的工作是否更有投入度、更满意呢？珍，是的，他们是。因此，我和我的合著者沙萨·德布罗、汉娜·韦斯曼以及丹尼·海勒一起进行了大约20年的调查，是一项关于体验工作作为天职意味着什么的量化调查。我们发现非常有力的证据表明，拥有强烈天职感的人报告对他们的工作、生活以及工作投入度有更高的满意度，并且在更好绩效的行为指标、更低的缺勤率方面也有所表现。关于如何以及为什么将工作体验为
as a calling matters. So Steve Jobs argued that having a calling allows you to work hard because you're working with passion, Do you find that? Is that borne out by the evidence? Are people with a calling? Do they have a higher propensity for hard work? In a study with Shasa Debrow and Heather Capus, we looked at this very question of do strong callings lead to greater effort? And we found empirically that they do. So when you have a stronger calling, you will expend more effort on calling relevant tasks. So not just any task, right? It has to be sort of, so if my calling is toward my work, domain, and then I'll put. in more effort at work, the mechanism through which this happens is through enjoyment of that work. So stronger calling means I enjoy the work more. Therefore, I will work harder at it. So this is the idea that if you love what you do, then you'll never work a day in your life. It's that idea. Exactly right.
天职至关重要，这些是各项研究中一致的发现。因此，史蒂夫·乔布斯认为，拥有天职能让你努力工作，因为你是带着激情在工作。你是否发现了这一点？证据是否证实了这一点？拥有天职的人有更高的努力工作倾向吗？在与沙萨·德布罗和希瑟·卡普斯合作的一项研究中，我们探讨了“强烈的天职是否会导致更大的努力”这一具体问题。我们在实证上发现，它们确实如此。因此，当你拥有更强烈的呼唤感时，你会为与呼唤相关的任务付出更多的努力。所以不只是任何任务，对吧？它必须是这样的，所以如果我的天职是针对我的工作领域，那么我就会在工作中投入更多的努力。发生这种情况的机制是通过对该工作的享受。因此，更强的呼唤感意味着我更享受这项工作。因此，我会为之付出更多的努力。这就是所谓的“如果你热爱你所做的事，你这一生就不会觉得在工作一天”的想法。正是那个想法。完全正确。
So other research finds that people who have a calling are more resilient. There are able to better withstand setbacks. Why would this be the case, Jen? Yeah, so a calling could almost be like a deep reserve of resilience, of connection to the work, the sense that even if things are not going well in work, that somehow my connection to the work that I'm doing, my belief in my ability to do it can help me to overcome a setback. You conducted a study of officers serving in the U.S. military and compared people who felt a calling to those who did not. Tell me about the study and what you found. Yeah, so this was with Marco Dorenzo and Ned Pauley. We conducted a survey of military officers. So they were mid-career, sort of junior officers, but with supervisory experience, they had about 10 to 12 years of service on average in the military. And we specifically looked at their perception that they had hit a career.
所以其他研究发现，拥有天职的人更有韧性。他们能够更好地抵御挫折。为什么会这样呢，珍？是的，天职几乎可以像是一处深厚的韧性储备，是对工作的深厚连接，这种感觉是，即使工作进展不顺利，某种程度上，我对正在做的工作的连接、对我有能力完成它的信念，也能帮助我克服挫折。你对在美国军队服役的军官进行了一项研究，并将那些感到有天职感的人与没有这种感觉的人进行了比较。跟我讲讲这项研究以及你的发现。是的，这是我和马可·多伦佐以及内德·保利一起做的。我们对军官进行了一项调查。所以他们是处于职业生涯中期的基层军官，但有监督经验，他们在军队平均有大约10到12年的服兵期。我们专门观察了他们对已经触及职业生涯瓶颈的感知，
plateau, which is just what it sounds like. So rather than this sense that I'm on the typical career upward trajectory that is desired, that I have leveled off, basically this subjective sense that I'm not learning and growing and developing in my current career. And we found that the stronger their callings toward the military, the less likely they were to perceive that they were at a plateaued space in their career, that in turn drove their commitment to staying in the military as an organization. So Steve Jobs told us that following a calling helped him be more creative. Is there any evidence that that is the case more generally? Stronger callings mean you're just more deeply connected to that domain. You might want to learn more about it. You might
这正如其字面意思。因此，比起那种认为我正处于所期望的典型职业上升轨迹的感觉，我已经趋于平缓，基本上是一种主观感觉，即我在当前的职业生涯中没有在学习、成长和发展。我们发现，他们对军队的呼唤感越强烈，他们越不可能认为自己处于职业生涯的停滞期，这反过来又推动了他们作为组织留在军队的承诺。所以史蒂夫·乔布斯告诉我们，追随天职帮助他变得更有创造力。有什么证据表明更普遍的情况也是如此吗？更强烈的呼唤感意味着你与该领域的连接更深。你可能想对它了解更多。你可能想花
want to spend more time doing it. Employees with strong callings might expend resources that other employees who don't feel as strongly just simply aren't as willing to expend. So this notion that like Steve Jobs, like Oprah, like everyone else we talked about, a calling might mean an engulfment or immersion in the work that leads to breakthroughs. I will say we need more research to support these conclusions, but the notion that experiencing a strong calling has leads people to do great work or their best work is very well-founded. So in your own career, Jen, you started out as a management consultant. What was that work like for you? Yeah, I, so I was an undergraduate business major and getting a job as a management consultant
更多时间去做它。有强烈天职感的员工可能会消耗其他感觉没那么强烈的员工 simplesmente 不愿意消耗的资源。因此，这种观念就像史蒂夫·乔布斯、奥普拉以及我们谈到的其他人一样，天职可能意味着对工作的全身心投入或沉浸，从而带来突破。我要说的是，我们需要更多的研究来支持这些结论，但体验到强烈的呼唤感会促使人们做出伟大的工作或他们最好的工作，这种观点是有据可依的。所以在你自己的职业生涯中，珍，你一开始是一名管理顾问。那段工作对你来说是怎样的？是的，我，所以我是一名本科商科专业学生，在纽约市一家大公司找到一份管理顾问的工作就像是一个梦想，因为我赚的钱看起来多得不合理。我与聪明、非常有趣的人共事。咨询工作是以项目为基础的，所以它不会变得乏味。你总是在四处移动，新的组织，新的环境，有时是一个新的城市。有旅行。我当时年轻且无拘无束。这一切都非常迷人，获得酒店积分和所有这些东西，飞行常客里程。但尽管我有所有这些客观的理由去热爱这份工作，我从未觉得咨询绝对是我的天职，甚至坦率地说，也不是我想一直留在那里的东西。我也注意到这种真实的性别差距。我认为这已经有所改善，可能没有彻底改善，但在咨询公司内部有所改善，但这是一种典型的情况，你会看到很多主要由男性组成的合伙人，他们在家有家人、孩子。但是女性合伙人，尽管人数很少，主要都是单身，没有孩子。我一直在想，这真的是我想要的生活吗？但也是，这真的是我能想象自己一直在做的工作吗？可能需要一周出差四到五天。最终，我决定并非如此，我需要做点别的。所以你最终离开了咨询公司，成为了一名学者。珍，作为一名教师和研究员，你感到这是一种天职吗？是的，我确实感到这是一种天职。我感到非常幸运，能够研究这些我一生都在好奇的问题，真的。比如，为什么人们要在工作上花这么多时间和精力？为什么工作在很大程度上定义了我们？当我们去参加派对，有人问“你是做什么的？”，我们知道这意味着什么。这意味着你是靠什么谋生的。这并不意味着“你平时一般都做什么？”，对吧？在美国，在东北部，也就是我大部分时间生活的地方，你做什么，你就是什么。我一直想对此有更多的了解。因此，能够研究这个课题，并与真实的人交谈，发现更多关于这如何与他们产生共鸣的事情。我的意思是，这真是太棒了。是的。我不得不说，你知道，我甚至不需要问你是否觉得自己在追求天职这个问题，因为当你在说话时，我几乎可以从你的声音中听出来。
at a big firm in New York City was like a dream because I was making more money than seemed reasonable. I was working with smart, very interesting people. Consulting work is project-based, so it doesn't get boring. You're always moving around, new organization, new setting, sometimes a new city. There was travel. I was young and unencumbered. It was all very glamorous, getting hotel points and all these kinds of things, frequent flyer miles. But despite all these sort of objective reasons for me to love the work, I never felt like consulting was certainly my calling or even frankly something I wanted to stay in. And I also noticed this real gender gap. And this has gotten, I think, somewhat better, probably not all the way better, but somewhat better
在纽约市一家大公司工作就像是一场梦，因为我赚到的钱多得似乎有些离谱。我和聪明、非常有趣的人一起工作。咨询工作是基于项目的，所以它不会让人感到无聊。你总是在到处奔波，新的组织，新的环境，有时甚至是一个新的城市。有出差。我当时年轻且无牵无挂。这一切都非常迷人，能攒酒店积分、各种各样的东西以及常旅客里程。但是，尽管有所有这些客观理由让我热爱这份工作，我从未觉得咨询绝对是我的天命，坦白说甚至也不是我想长期从事的事情。而且我也注意到了这种真正的性别差距。我认为这种情况已经有所好转，可能还没有彻底改变，但确实有所好转。
within consulting firms, but it was this classic thing where you would see a lot of predominantly male partners who had, you know, families, kids at home. But the female partners, few as they are, were primarily single, no children. And I'm just thinking both, is this the life that I want, but also is this the work that I can really see myself doing, traveling potentially, four or five days a week. And ultimately, I decided that it was not and that I needed to do something else. So you eventually left the consulting firm and you became an academic. Do you feel a colleague when it comes to being a teacher and a researcher, Jay? Yeah, I do feel a calling. And I feel so fortunate to be able to study these questions that I've wondered about my whole
我能听到你对自己所做事情的热情。我觉得往往就是这样，当你遇到那些有天职感的人时，几乎就像他们恨不得跳出来告诉你他们正在做的事情是多么美妙。而他们所做的事情可能相当晦涩，对你来说可能毫无兴趣，但他们在某种程度上展现的热情会感染到你。我认为这绝对是对的。我甚至想说，对于在组织中工作的人来说，听到每个人对工作的感受可能都不会感到惊讶。我认为，你可以从他们对工作的投入中感受到某种无形的东西，也许是他们对工作的着迷，他们对工作的感受，这些都会流露出来。这看起来似乎十拿九稳。史蒂夫·乔布斯是对的。我们所有人都应该找到并追求我们的天职。但正如你从收听这个节目中所了解到的，人性是无比复杂的。在一个领域对我们有利的东西，在另一个领域可能成为障碍。稍后我们将回来，探讨天职的消极面。你正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”。我是香卡·维丹坦。
life, really. Like, why do people spend so much time at work? Why does work define us to the extent that it does when we go to parties and someone says, what do you do? We know what that means. That means what do you do for a living? It doesn't mean like, what do you do in general, right? In the U.S. and in the Northeast, which is where I've mostly lived, what you do is who you are. I wanted to understand always more about that. So being able to study that and to talk to real people and find out more about how this resonates with them. I mean, that is the best. Yeah. I have to say that, you know, I almost didn't need to ask you the question of whether you are, whether you feel like you are pursuing a calling, because I can almost hear it in your voice as you're talking.
生活，真的。比如，为什么人们花那么多时间在工作上？为什么工作对我们的定义会达到这种程度：当我们去参加派对时，有人问“你是做什么的？”，我们都知道这意味着什么。那意味着你以什么为生？它并不意味着“你平时一般都做些什么”，对吧？在美国，在东北部，也就是我大部分时间生活过的地方，你做什么就代表你是谁。我一直想对此有更多的了解。因此，能够研究这个课题，与真人交谈，并了解更多关于这如何引起他们的共鸣。我的意思是，这简直棒极了。是的。我不得不说，你知道的，我几乎不需要问你这样一个问题：你是否正在追求天命，或者你是否觉得自己在追求天命，因为当你在说话时，我几乎能从你的声音中听出来。
I can hear your enthusiasm for what it is that you do. And I feel like that's often the case, that when you come by people who have a calling, it's almost as if they are jumping out of themselves to tell you how wonderful it is the thing that they're doing. And what they are doing could be quite obscure and could have no interest whatsoever to you, but their enthusiasm in some ways rubs off on you. I think that's absolutely right. I would go so far as to say it probably wouldn't be a surprise to people working in an organization to hear from each person how they feel about their work. I think there would be something intangible that you could sense about their engagement with the work, maybe their obsession with the work, how they feel about the work
我能听到你对你所做的事情的热情。我觉得通常情况确实如此，当你遇到拥有天命的人时，他们几乎就像是要从自己身上跳出来告诉你，他们所做的事情是多么美妙。而他们所做的事情可能非常晦涩难懂，可能对你完全没有任何吸引力，但他们在某些方面的热情会感染到你。我认为这绝对是正确的。我甚至可以说，对于在组织中工作的人来说，听到每个人对工作的感受，大概不会让人感到意外。我认为会有一种无形的东西，你能感受到他们对工作的投入，也许还有他们对工作的痴迷，以及他们对工作的感受。
that would come through. It can seem like a slam dunk. Steve Jobs was right. All of us should find and pursue our callings. But human nature, as you know from listening to the show, is endlessly complicated. What serves us well in one domain can be an impediment in another. When we come back, the downsides of callings. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
这里是“隐藏的大脑”。我是香卡·维丹坦。当你正在收听这期“隐藏的大脑”时，我是香卡·维丹坦。当你正在收听这期节目时，你是否觉得你听到的正是在描述你自己——一个找到了自己命中注定要做什么的人，一个拥有超越自身的使命感和激情的人？或者你是否对那些找到了天职的人感到羡慕，并怀疑自己是否也能找到类似的东西？如果你有关于拥有天职的故事或问题，
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. As you're listening to This Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. As you're listening to this episode, Do you feel like you're hearing a description of yourself, someone who has found what they were meant to do, someone with a purpose and a passion that transcends them? Or do you feel envy of people who have found their calling and wonder whether you'll ever find something similar? If you have stories or questions about having a calling
愿意与“隐藏的大脑”听众分享，请去一个非常安静的房间，在你的手机上录下一条语音备忘录。将其电邮至 Ideas at HiddenBrain.com。使用主题行：calling。再次重复那个电子邮件地址是 Ideas at hiddenbrain.org。西格蒙德·弗洛伊德曾说过，人类幸福有两个来源。一个是爱，另一个是工作。与他人建立紧密的、亲密的、个人的联系对于繁荣至关重要。
that you'd be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience, please go to a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Email it to us at Ideas at HiddenBrain.com. Use the subject line, calling. That email address again is Ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Sigmund Freud said there are two sources of human happiness. There was love and there was work. Close, intimate, personal ties with other people are essential to flourishing.
朋友、家人和爱人使生命值得活下去。但同样地，他认为，表明我们正在对世界产生影响的工作也可以成为持久满足感的源泉。在巴布森学院，詹妮弗·托斯蒂·卡里斯发现这是真的。有意义的工作是幸福的源泉。与哲学家克里斯托弗·王·米歇尔森一起，她是《你的工作值得吗？如何思考有意义的工作》一书的作者。珍，拥有天职的想法在我们的文化中备受推崇，
Friends, families, and lovers make life worth living. But equally, he argued. work that shows we are making a difference in the world can be a source of enduring satisfaction. At Babson College, Jennifer Toasty-Carris has found that this is true. Meaningful work is a source of happiness. Along with a philosopher, Christopher Wong Michelson, she is the author of the book, Is Your Work Worth It? How to Think About Meaningful Work. Jen, the idea of having a calling is so celebrated in our culture,
以至于许多人可能会感到惊讶，天职其实也有消极面。但你和其他人发现，追求职业确实可能会有弊端。首先，追求天职似乎会扭曲我们的判断力。你曾在音乐家的背景下专门探讨过这个想法。你发现了什么？是的。首先，我同意这会让人们感到惊讶，因为我们已经深深地将“做你所爱的事，金钱随之而来”、“找到你的天职”、“热爱你的生活”这样的文化信息内化了。这些简直是
that it might come as a surprise to many people that callings can have downsides. But you and others have found that they can be drawbacks to pursuing a vocation. For one thing, pursuing a calling seems to distort our judgment. You've looked at this idea specifically in the context of musicians. What do you find? Yeah. So I agree, first of all, that this is startling to people because we have so encoded this cultural message of do what you love, the money will follow, find your calling, love your life. These are literally
书籍的标题，看起来是如此显而易见。你知道，我找到了我的天职，剩下的都是额外的收获。但现实看起来截然不同，而音乐家是一个引人入胜的研究对象，因为这既是一个典型的艺术领域，对吧？我们可以想象会看到很多天职，对音乐有大量的激情，这是我们许多人以这样或那样的形式确实在追求的东西，然而这是一个非常充满风险的职业，因为我们知道，并不是每个想成为专业音乐家的人都能如愿以偿，就像体育、艺术一样，很多不同的领域都是这样运作的。所以我做了一系列研究，我的合著者沙萨·德布罗也做了一系列有趣的研究。她不仅是伦敦政治经济学院的教授，还是一名职业大管演奏家。所以她对这个世界非常非常熟悉。因此，她在长期的职业生涯中一直在研究音乐家，长达11年之久，而且还在继续。她开始研究他们时，他们正在一个
book titles that seem so obvious. You know, I find my calling and the rest is gravy. But the reality looks very different and musicians are fascinating to study because this is both a quintessential arts field, right? We would imagine to see a lot of callings, a lot of passion toward music, It's something, you know, a lot of us do pursue in some way or another, but yet it's a very fraught profession because we know that not everyone will make it as a professional musician who might want to in the same way with sports, arts, lots of different fields operate like this. So I've done a series of studies and there's a series of interesting studies that have been done by my co-author, Shasa de Brough. She is not only a professor at the London School of Economics, but she is a professional bassoonist. So she knows this world very, very well. So she has been studying musicians over a long career span, so 11 years and counting. And she started studying them when they were in a program
针对在音乐方面很有天赋的高中生项目中，她评估了他们对音乐的天职水平，然后几年后观察他们是否最终以音乐为职业？不出所料，呼唤感越强烈，人们日后以音乐为职业的可能性就越大，但其中的驱动因素之一并不是我们可能认为的实际能力或天赋水平，而是他们对自己有天赋的感知。事实上，随着强烈的天职感，人们往往对自己能力水平的感知过高。所以他们觉得自己比实际情况更好。这反过来促使他们去追求这个相当有风险的职业道路。
for talented high school students who were talented at music, and she assessed their level of calling toward music, then saw years later, do they pursue music professionally or not? Maybe not surprisingly, the stronger the calling, the more likely people are to pursue music professionally down the road, but that one of the drivers of this is not their actual ability or talent level, as we might think, but their perception that they're talented. And that actually with strong callings, people tend to have overinflated perception of their own ability level. So they think they're better than they are. And that leads them then to pursue this pretty risky career path.
因此，这就引发了一种观点，即强烈的呼唤感可能会导致一种职业思维定势，在那里你真的无法想象自己不会成功，因为我太热爱它了。你知道，当这是我的激情，这是我的天职时，我怎么可能不是那个取得突破的人呢？当拥有天职的人从其他人那里得到反馈或指导，发现其实他们并没有自己想象的那么好时，会发生什么呢？是的，他们不听取那种反馈。
So that started this idea that strong callings might lead to a sort of a career tunnel vision where you truly can't imagine that you won't make it because I love it so much. You know, how can I not be the one to break through when this is my passion and this is my calling? What happens when people who have a calling get feedback or guidance from others that in fact they're not as good as they think they are? Yeah, they do not listen to that feedback.
所以沙萨和我专门在音乐家的背景下研究了这一点。我们发现的是，音乐家的音乐呼唤感越强，如果音乐老师劝阻他们不要从事音乐，他们就越不可能听从私人音乐老师的建议。他们基本上会说，非常感谢。我不同意。我还是要这么做。为了不让我们认为这种现象仅限于或特定于音乐家、音乐背景或艺术，我们在商学院学生的样本中复制了这完全相同的发现，他们表示，他们对商业的天职感越强，他们越不会接受受人信任的导师的建议——我们将这个留得更开放一些——一个劝阻他们以商业为职业的受信任导师。因此，关于强烈的天职，确实似乎存在某种东西，
So Shasa and I have studied this specifically in the context of musicians. And so what we found was the stronger musicians calling toward music, the less likely they were to follow the advice of their private music teacher if that music teacher discouraged them from going into music. They would basically say, thank you very much. I disagree. I'm doing it anyway. And lest we think this phenomenon is limited to or specific to musicians or the context of music or the arts, we replicated this exact. finding in a sample of business school students who said the stronger their callings toward business they would not accept the advice of a trusted mentor we left this one more open a trusted mentor who discouraged them from going into business professionally so there does seem to be something about strong
而且很容易就会说，为什么这是一件坏事？我们难道不应该有一种感觉，就像我想要做这个，没有什么能阻止我，也没有人或任何东西能劝阻我吗？事实上，许多这些原型的、你知道的呼唤故事，就像我们之前分享的，史蒂夫·Jobs等人的故事，都是关于克服这些逆境的，对吧？尽管有违背我的重重困难，我还是坚持了下来，我取得了突破并成功了。我认为这在一定程度上是正确的。显然，拥有一点自信，甚至可能有一点点自我认知的过高，
callings and and it would be very easy to say well why is this a bad thing shouldn't we have a sense that we are like I want to do this and nothing's going to stop me and no one or nothing can dissuade me. In fact, a lot of these archetypal, you know, calling stories like we shared earlier, Steve Jobs, etc., it's about overcoming these odds, right? Despite everything stacked against me, I persevered, and I broke through and I made it. And I think that can be true to a point. Obviously, having some self-confidence or even maybe a little bit of an overinflated self-perception
可能会有所帮助，或者可能是适应性的，或者可能有助于增强韧性。但很难不让人觉得，当到了某个地步，无法听取那些对我们抱有最大善意、给我们真实反馈的人的意见时，这种无法倾听的无能会在某种程度上伤害我们。有许多天职并不涉及赚大钱。我在想艺术。我在想音乐。我在想许多情况下的体育，也许不是所有体育，但许多体育。珍，关于追求天职的经济影响，我们知道些什么？是的。所以你完全正确，那些更具
might be helpful or might be adaptive or might help with resilience. But it's hard not to think that there comes a point when an inability to listen to people that have our best interests at heart who are telling us, giving us real feedback, that the inability to listen to this might harm us in some way. There are many callings that do not. involve making a lot of money. I'm thinking about the arts. I'm thinking about music. I'm thinking about sports in many cases, perhaps not all sports, but many sports. What do we know about the economic impacts of pursuing a calling, Jen? Yeah. So you're absolutely right that the more
原型的以天职为导向的职业，无论是慈善工作、帮助工作、国际援助工作等，往往薪酬不高。因此，许多人为了追求天职或一般意义上的有意义的工作，已经在被含蓄地要求接受降薪，相比于“我要去那家大银行工作并且不问太多问题，对吧？我要去，你知道，我要去一家大型律所工作，并且不问太多关于我的客户是谁之类的问题。”因此，我们已经有这样一种感觉，即我们要求社会中的人们把他们对自己所做事情的热情或从工作中获得的意义用来替代薪水。但实际上，我们在我自己的研究和其他人的研究中发现，拥有更强烈天职感的人实际上会为了做他们热爱的工作而做出经济牺牲。所以突然间问题变成了，这是否可能是过度工作，而这基本上让人们容易被利用？我的意思是，我正想问你这个问题，也就是说，如果一个人愿意在不真正寻求或要求报酬的情况下工作，因为他们说我在追求我的激情。难道这不让他们容易受到剥削吗？绝对是。所以这也是我教给我的学生、我要真正提醒人们的事情，因为我们已经说过，这些是好员工，这些是组织真正想要吸引和真正想要留住的人。那么如果除此之外，我真的觉得，天哪，无论我要求你做什么，我要求你在下班后、一天或夜晚的任何时间来，总是超越自我。哦，我知道我不能指望我的其他员工，但我真的能指望你。你知道，在什么点上这是不公平的？这是否是剥削性的？这是否以一种消耗精力的、坦率地说会导致职业倦怠的方式侵入了个人空间、个人生活？事实上，这也是一些研究所发现的，拥有更强烈天职感的人，好听的说法是他们超越自我，是他们理想的员工。
prototypical calling-oriented professions, whether it's nonprofit work, helping work, you know, international aid work, et cetera, tend to not be well paid. So already many people to pursue their callings or meaningful work in general are being asked implicitly to accept a pay cut relative to I'm going to go work for that big bank and not ask too many questions, right? I'm going to go work for, you know, I'm going to work in a big law firm and not ask too many questions about who my clients are, things like that. So already we have some sense that we ask people in society to take their love for what they're doing or the meaning they get from the work they do and substitute it for pay. But actually, we have found this in my own research
更负面的说法是，他们会牺牲个人时间，即使没有报酬，结果他们会报告更大的身心健康问题、更大的疲劳、压力、倦怠，并最终会离职，因为以这种速度继续工作根本是不可持续的。
and the research of others, that people with stronger callings will actually make financial sacrifices to do the work that they love doing. So suddenly the question becomes, is this potentially overwork and that basically sets people up to be taken advantage of? I mean, I was just going to ask you this question, which is if someone is willing to work without really seeking or demanding pay because they're saying I'm pursuing my passion. Doesn't that make them vulnerable to exploitation? Absolutely. And so that's something that I teach my students about and that I would really caution people about because we've already said that these are the good workers and that these are people that organizations really want to attract and really want to retain. So then if on
以及其他人的研究表明，拥有更强使命感的人实际上会为了做他们热爱的工作而做出经济牺牲。所以突然间，问题变成了：这是否可能是过度工作，这基本上是否会让人陷入容易被剥削的境地？我的意思是，我正想问你这个问题：如果有人愿意工作而不去真正寻求或要求报酬，因为他们说我在追求我的热情。这难道不会使他们容易受到剥削吗？绝对会。所以这是我教导我的学生的一点，也是我真正想告诫人们的一点，因为我们刚才已经说过，这些是优秀的员工，是组织真正想要吸引和真正想要留住的人。那么如果在
top of that, I really feel like, gosh, no matter what I ask you to do, I ask you to come in, you know, off hours, all times of day or night, always go above and beyond. Oh, I know I can't count on my other employees, but I can really count on you. You know, at what point is it unfair? Is it exploitative? And is it pushing into a personal space, you know, personal life in a way that is depleting and, frankly, would lead to burnout? And in fact, that is what some studies have found, is that people with stronger callings, the good way to say it is they go above and beyond, their ideal employees.
除此之外，我真的觉得，天哪，不管我要求你做什么，我要求你来，你知道的，在非工作时间，无论白天还是黑夜的任何时间，总是超越自我。哦，我知道我不能指望我的其他员工，但我真的能指望你。你知道的，在什么情况下这算是不公平？这算不算剥削？它是否正在以一种消耗精力的、坦白说会导致精疲力竭的方式侵入个人空间、个人生活？事实上，这也是一些研究所发现的，拥有更强使命感的人，好听一点的说法是他们超越自我，是理想的员工。
The more negative way to say it is, they will sacrifice personal time, even when it's not paid, and they can as a result report greater physical and psychological health issues, greater fatigue, stress, burnout, and ultimately will leave jobs because it's simply unsustainable to keep working at this pace.
而比较负面的说法是，他们会牺牲个人时间，甚至在没有报酬的情况下也是如此，因此他们会报告出更多的身体和心理健康问题、更大的疲劳、压力、精疲力竭，并最终会辞职，因为以这种节奏继续工作根本是不可持续的。
You tell the story about a man named Colin Huggins. What is this story and how is it germane to what we're talking about here, Jen? Yeah, so this is another musician's story. Colin Huggins is a busker. So he plays his 900-pound Steinway Baby Grand piano in the middle of Washington Square Park. So listeners may have stumbled upon him if they've walked through Washington Square Park and heard absolutely beautiful classical music being played. He would literally lug this piano from his apartment in the East Village over to Washington
你讲了一个关于科林·哈金斯的人的故事。这个故事是什么？它跟我们今天讨论的话题有什么关系呢，詹姆？是的，所以这是另一个音乐家的故事。科林·哈金斯是一个街头艺人。他把重达900磅的斯坦威小三角钢琴搬到华盛顿广场公园中央弹奏。所以听众如果走过华盛顿广场公园，听到绝对优美的古典音乐，可能偶然遇到过他。他真的会把这架钢琴从东村的公寓拉到华盛顿
Square Park and the moving blankets he would lay under the piano and invite people to lay down under the piano so they could really experience the wall of sound that he was producing. He was doing this by choice. He used to be a professional accompanist for the Joffrey Ballet. He described that once he got a taste of this public performance, he was hooked. So he, you know, experienced a strong passion for music, a strong passion for public performance. And it may come as no surprise. This was not a lucrative way to make a living even pre-COVID.
广场公园，并在钢琴下面铺上搬家毯子，邀请人们躺在钢琴下面，这样他们就能真正体验到他所产生的音墙。他这样做是出于选择。他曾经是乔弗瑞芭蕾舞团的专业伴奏。他描述说，一旦他尝到了这种公开表演的滋味，他就迷上了。所以，你知道的，他对音乐有着强烈地热爱，对公开表演有着强烈地热爱。这也许并不令人意外。即使在新冠疫情之前，这也是一种赚不到什么钱的谋生方式。
But the last, and this is a, so this is already representing a real sacrifice to do one's work, but the last that I had read about Colin Huggins, and again, he's this beloved, you know, piano man of the village and of Washington Square Park. This was in 2023. It was reported that he was homeless, so couldn't keep paying the rent in the East Village, and was in fact sleeping in the park on his piano. So this is a terribly tragic, very poignant story of sort of ultimate sacrifice to do work that one loves, sort of with very little concern about even meeting basic needs. So many people switch jobs as new opportunities come up, and if you don't like one job,
但最后，这是一个，所以这已经体现了为自己的工作做出真正牺牲的事情，但我最后一次读到关于科林·哈金斯的消息时，而且再次强调，他是这个村庄和华盛顿广场公园备受喜爱的，你知道的钢琴人。那是在2023年。据报道他无家可归了，因此无法继续支付东村的房租，事实上是睡在公园的钢琴上。所以这是一个极其悲惨、非常辛酸的故事，为了做自己热爱的工作，甚至很少关心是否能满足基本需求，从而做出了某种终极牺牲。很多人在有新机会时换工作，如果你不喜欢一份工作，
you can go to another job. But if you're pursuing a calling and your career doesn't work out as planned, this feels emotionally very different than someone who loses a job or gets laid off from a position. I mean, they're both painful, but if you feel like you're doing something you're called to do and it's deeply meaningful to you, losing out in a career like that can be very, very difficult. Can you talk about this idea that in some ways, one of the downsides of having a calling is what happens when it doesn't work out as a career? Absolutely. So not everyone is lucky enough to find work in their calling to begin with.
你可以换到另一份工作。但如果你在追求天职，而你的职业生涯没有按计划发展，这在情感上感觉与失去工作或被解雇的人截然不同。我的意思是，这两种情况都很痛苦，但如果你觉得你在做你命中注定要做的事情，而且这对你意义重大，那么在这样的职业生涯中失利可能会非常非常困难。你能谈谈这种观点吗？在某些方面，拥有天职的缺点之一就是当它作为一种职业失败时会发生什么？绝对的。所以并不是每个人都那么幸运，一开始就能在天职中找到工作。
Similarly, not everyone is able to sustain work in the calling, and we can imagine that could be for a lot of reasons people might not be able to pursue their callings. And research by Justin Berg and others has shown that this is a deeply psychologically aversive state filled with frustration, regret, depression, because it's not just, I need a job, any job. You sort of have this notion that it's really got to live up to this high sense that I have of what work should be. It's worth also pointing out, Jen, that the effects of the choices we make are not
同样，并不是每个人都能维持天职中的工作，我们可以想象这可能是出于很多原因，人们可能无法追求他们的天职。贾斯汀·伯格和其他人的研究表明，这是一种深层心理厌恶状态，充满了挫折、后悔、抑郁，因为这不仅仅是，我需要一份工作，任何工作。你会有这种观念，认为它必须真正符合我对工作应该是什么的高标准。詹姆，还值得指出的是，我们所做选择的影响并不是
experienced only by ourselves. The people around us are affected as well. We talked earlier about how the painter Paul Gogan left France to try his luck as an artist in Tahiti. Now, he may have gone into the history books as a great artist, but talk a moment about the impact of his choices on the people around him. What does that legacy look like? Not such a good legacy, Shankar. So Paul Gogan, today, in the parlance of today, should be canceled. Or we believe he should be canceled because he,
仅仅由我们自己承受的。我们周围的人也会受到影响。我们之前讨论过画家保罗·高更如何离开法国，去塔希提岛碰运气成为一名艺术家。现在，他可能作为一位伟大的艺术家载入史册，但请花一点时间谈谈他的选择对周围人的影响。那种传奇是什么样子的？不是什么好传奇，尚卡尔。所以保罗·高更，在今天的用语中，应该被取消。或者我们认为他应该被取消，因为他，
led a life of utter selfishness at the expense of his family. He left his family behind in France when he went to Tahiti. So first of all, he was no longer there to contribute. And as we said, he was not doing so well by selling his art in Polynesia that he could send money home to them. So another way to say this is he abandoned his family in France. And to go one step further, by all accounts, I mean, Paul Gogan is now a very kind of, his legacy is somewhat conflicted by the fact that he pursued women that he painted and had, you know, by all accounts, affairs with them. there's a story that his favorite child died and he still did not return home. And by all accounts, it sort of led to his downfall.
过着极其自私的生活，牺牲了家人的利益。他去塔希提岛时把家人留在了法国。首先，他不在那里做贡献了。正如我们所说，他在波利尼西亚卖画并没有做得很好，以至于可以寄钱回家给他们。换句话说，他抛弃了法国的家人。更进一步说，根据所有人的说法，我的意思是，保罗·高更现在非常，他的传奇由于以下事实而有些矛盾：他追求他画的女性，并且根据所有人的说法，与她们有染。有一个故事说他最喜欢的孩子死了，他还是没有回家。根据所有人的说法，这可以说是他垮台的原因。
He went sort of mad and, you know, kind of consumed by his own, you know, obsession to paint. But it was sort of this all-consuming passion or obsession. And he died in Polynesia without having returned home to this family that he essentially. eventually left behind. Being swept up by a calling can make people obsessive and single-minded. That might be good for the pursuit of passion, but it can be harmful for other dimensions of life, from your physical health to your relationships with family and friends.
他有点发疯了，你知道的，被他自己的，你知道的，画画的执念所吞噬。但这是一种消耗一切的激情或执念。他在波利尼西亚去世，没有回到他本质上抛弃的这个家庭。被天职吞没会让人变得执着和专注。这对追求激情可能是件好事，但对生活的其他方面可能会有害，从你的身体健康到与家人和朋友的关系。
So often it seems, the good and the bad go hand in hand when it comes to callings. Yeah, I would agree with that. I think it's certainly something that people should be aware of and look out for. So I think just in the same way that it might be this excuse, you know, we don't have to pay you as much because you really love it. It also might be an excuse to not engage fully in areas outside of work because I'm so consumed by work and my work is the most important thing to me. At what point do other domains of life, whatever those are, whether they're a family who depends on you, whether they're, you. you know, just self-care and the cultivation of a life outside work, which has, you know, merit and benefit, at what point do those things suffer because of this kind of all-in sense of performing the work?
所以通常看起来，谈到天职时，好事和坏事总是如影随形。是的，我同意这一点。我认为这肯定是人们应该意识到并密切关注的事情。所以我认为，就像这可能是一个借口一样，你知道的，我们不必付给你那么多钱，因为你真的很喜欢它。这也可能成为不充分参与工作以外领域的借口，因为我太全神贯注于工作，我的工作对我来说是最重要的。在什么时候，生活的其他领域，无论它们是什么，无论是依赖你的家庭，无论是你，
Hmm. You know, it's interesting. We've talked about how the idea of having a calling is a romantic idea, but I can't stop seeing the parallels with actual romance. So a century or two ago, everyone thought that work was just how you paid the bills. But similarly, you know, a couple centuries ago, marriage was a very prosaic institution designed primarily for raising children. Today, people want romantic partners who are going to be their soulmates. Similarly, people with a calling might ignore good advice. People in love can be blind to reason.
你知道的，只是自我关怀和在工作之外培养生活，这具有，你知道的，价值和好处，在什么时候这些事情会因为这种全情投入的工作表现而受到影响？嗯。你知道，这很有趣。我们讨论过拥有天职的想法是一个浪漫的想法，但我无法停止看到它与真正的浪漫之间的相似之处。所以在一两个世纪前，每个人都认为工作只是你支付账单的方式。但同样地，你知道的，几个世纪前，婚姻是一个非常平淡的制度，主要是为了抚养孩子而设计的。今天，人们想要将浪漫伴侣作为灵魂伴侣。同样，有天职的人可能会忽视好的建议。陷入爱河的人可能对理性视而不见。
And if having a calling that doesn't work out can leave you broken-hearted, failing at love, can also leave you grief-stricken. And I'm wondering psychologically, do you think, some ways there are the same processes that are at work here. I think they are, I think that is so well said, and I think they are very similar processes. I want to remind listeners who maybe haven't heard the Steve Jobs commencement speech in a while, he makes this parallel. He says, don't settle, keep looking until you found that perfect fit, that job that you love. It's as important in your work life as it is with your romantic partners. I mean, he makes this literal
如果拥有一个没有结果的天职会让你心碎，那么在爱情中失败也会让你悲痛欲绝。我想知道在心理学上，你认为在某些方面这里是否有相同的过程在起作用。我认为是的，我认为这话讲得太好了，而且我认为它们是非常相似的过程。我想提醒那些可能有一段时间没听史蒂夫·乔布斯毕业典礼演讲的听众，他进行了这种类比。他说，不要将就，继续寻找，直到你找到那个完美的契合点，那份你热爱的工作。这在你的工作生活中和在你的浪漫伴侣中一样重要。我的意思是，他做出了这个字面上的
parallel to a romantic search and the search for the perfect job. And just as this is a very high bar to live up to in your romantic life, this is a very high bar for any job to live up to. And again, the research bears this out. So people with stronger callings tend to be, so again, we've talked about how they're all in on work. They're very, you know, go above and beyond, think outside of the box. The flip side of this is they can be extremely critical of those around them, whether it's the organization, leaders, coworkers have a view that differs from their own. But in terms of actually performing the work, they can be quite tough to work with. They can have strained work relationships. They will be, you know, the first to sign up if someone needs to work
与浪漫寻觅以及寻找完美工作的寻觅的类比。正如这在你的浪漫生活中是一个很高的标准一样，这也是任何工作都很难达到的很高的标准。而且，研究再次证实了这一点。所以拥有更强烈天职倾向的人往往是，所以再次强调，我们讨论过他们对工作全情投入。他们非常，你知道的，超越常规，打破常规。这背后的另一面是，他们可能对周围的人极其挑剔，无论是组织、领导、同事，如果他们的观点与自己不同。但在实际执行工作方面，他们可能很难共事。他们的工作关系可能会很紧张。他们会是，你知道的，如果有人需要工作，第一个报名的人
extra hours, but also the first to complain if a decision is made that they don't agree with or that they, because again, it runs counter to my calling. So to have this lofty ideal of what the perfect job is going to feel like is just as sort of unrealistic an assumption as thinking when I find my perfect life partner, every day will be roses and sunshine and will never quarrel and nothing will ever feel hard again. These are myths. You know, some time ago we had the researcher Eli Finkel from Northwestern University on Hidden Brain, and he was making a very interesting argument. His argument was that as our expectations of our romantic partners have gone higher and higher and higher, fewer of us are actually able to
加班，但也是第一个抱怨做出了他们不同意的决定，或者他们，因为再次强调，这违背了我的天职。因此，对完美工作的感觉抱有这种崇高的理想，就像认为当我找到我的人生伴侣时，每一天都是玫瑰和阳光，永远不会争吵，没有任何事情会再感到困难一样，是一种不切实际的假设。这些都是神话。你知道，不久前，我们邀请了西北大学的研究员伊利·芬克尔来到“隐藏大脑”，他提出了一个非常有趣的观点。他的观点是，随着我们对浪漫伴侣的期望越来越高，我们当中真正能够
meet those expectations. So many of us, because our expectations for marriage have now become so much higher than they were two centuries ago, fewer of us are actually able to reach the level where we are satisfied or we say that we're in a happy relationship. But for those of us who actually are able to meet that standard, who are actually able to put in the time and the effort to cultivate great relationships, they're probably having much happier marriage. than people two centuries ago, but it also means that there are many, many people who feel like they're falling short. And again, I can't help but see the parallels here with having a calling. If you have a calling, you happen to be lucky enough to achieve that calling, you're doing
满足这些期望的人越来越少。我们中的许多人，因为我们对婚姻的期望现在比两个世纪前高得多，我们中真正能够达到满足水平或者说我们处于幸福关系中的人数实际上更少了。但对于我们当中那些真正能够达到那个标准，真正能够投入时间和精力去培养伟大关系的人来说，他们的婚姻可能比两个世纪前的人幸福得多，但这也意味着有许许多多的人觉得自己没有达到标准。而且，我再次情不自禁地在这里看到了拥有天职的相似之处。如果你有天职，你碰巧足够幸运地实现了那个天职，你正在做
work that's meaningful, you're doing work that transforms the world. I mean, you're clearly happier than almost everyone in human history who's ever had a job, but if everyone aspires to that very, very high standard, lots of us are going to be disappointed. it. Yeah, that is a perfect parallel. So first, I think someone should do that study about exactly how do people feel about the expectation of the calling versus the I want to see that, you know, that type of study. But I also think that's right because we know that there are so many jobs that need doing that are unlikely to feel like people's calling. And so where does that leave people who are left out of this ability to, you know, choose work freely, work in areas that have a reasonable enough degree of autonomy that there's something that they can tap into?
有意义的工作，你正在做改变世界的工作。我的意思是，你显然比人类历史上几乎所有有过工作的人都要快乐，但如果每个人都渴望那个非常非常高的标准，我们中的许多人将会感到失望。是的，这是一个完美的类比。首先，我认为有人应该做那项研究，关于人们对天职期望与我的感受之间的确切态度。我想看到那个，你知道的，那类研究。但我也认为这是对的，因为我们知道有那么多需要完成的工作，它们不太可能让人觉得是人们的天职。那么，对于那些被剥夺了这种自由选择工作能力的人来说，他们处于什么位置呢，在具有足够合理自主权的领域工作，从而有什么东西是他们可以利用的？
I think that phenomenon will absolutely play out in a very similar way. I have to say that I feel torn here after this conversation because I think I want to live in a world that has Marie Curie's and Steve Jobses, but I can also see the great cost. that come from being so single-minded. After doing all this research and thinking, where do you come down, Jen? Our calling's a good thing? Yeah. So what I like to say is
我认为这种现象绝对会以非常相似的方式上演。我不得不说，在这次谈话之后，我在这里感到左右为难，因为我认为我想生活在一个拥有居里夫人和史蒂夫·乔布斯的世界里，但我也能看到如此专注所带来的巨大代价。在做了所有这些研究和思考之后，你得出了什么结论，詹姆？天职是件好事吗？是的。所以我喜欢说的是
absolutely people should not be doing work that feels meaning less, that is drudgery and that you believe is not just not making the world a better place but might actually be making the world a worse place. That's a fate I wouldn't want for anyone. So my great hope would be
绝对不应该有人去做那些感觉毫无意义、繁重且你认为不仅没有让世界变得更好，反而可能让世界变得更糟的工作。那是我不希望任何人遭遇的命运。所以我最大的希望是
that we as a society figure out, how to offer jobs that provide a path to a sense that the work is meaningful and and worthy of respect and human dignity. I do also want to say I don't think that feeling that work is a strong calling is the only path or the best path to feeling that you have a good life or a meaningful life. So there are lots of people. people who find the meaning in their life outside of the meaning of their work. So in some ways, it's sort of like what you had said. If you're lucky enough to find work that you love doing, that's great.
我们作为一个社会能够弄清楚，如何提供能够提供通往这样一种感觉的途径的工作：工作是有意义的，并且值得尊重和人的尊严。我还想说，我不认为觉得工作是强烈的天职是感觉自己拥有美好生活或有意义生活的唯一途径或最佳途径。所以有很多人。人们在工作意义之外的生活中寻找意义。所以在某些方面，这有点像你刚才说的。如果你足够幸运能找到你热爱的工作，那太棒了。
But I think for those who haven't yet found it or maybe we'll never find it, don't despair. That's not a personal or moral failing as we sometimes make it seem. And there are so many ways that we can feel like we're making a difference and a contribution. It doesn't only need to be through our work or primarily through our work. And there are lots of things that give our lives meaning that have nothing to do with work. Christopher Wong Michelson, are the authors of the book, Is Your Work Worth It? How to Think About Meaningful Work. In our companion story on Hidden Brain Plus, we'll look at how all of us, people who have a
但我想对于那些还没找到或者可能永远找不到的人，不要绝望。这并不是个人或道德上的失败，正如我们有时表现出来的那样。有很多方法可以让我们觉得我们在发挥作用并做出贡献。它不一定非要通过我们的工作，或者主要通过我们的工作。还有很多事情赋予我们的生活意义，而这些事情与工作无关。克里斯托弗·王·米切尔森是《你的工作值得吗？如何思考有意义的工作》一书的作者。在我们在“隐藏大脑Plus”上的配套故事中，我们将探讨我们所有人，包括那些拥有
calling and people who don't, people who want a calling and people who don't, can derive greater meaning and satisfaction from our work. We'll explore psychological techniques that can change your relationship to your job, your co-workers, and your profession. If you're a subscriber to Hidden Brain, that episode should be available in your feed right now. It's titled How to Make Work Meaningful. If you're not a subscriber, this is a great time to check out Hidden Brain Plus. All through the month of September, listeners who subscribe on Apple Podcasts will get access to an extended 30-day free trial. To access that 30-day trial, find Hidden Brain on Apple Podcasts and click the try-free button, or go to Apple.com slash Hidden Brain.
天职的人和没有天职的人，想要天职的人和不想要天职的人，如何从我们的工作中获得更大的意义和满足感。我们将探讨可以改变你与工作、同事和职业关系的心理学技巧。如果你是“隐藏大脑”的订阅者，该集现在应该可以在你的动态中获取。它的标题是《如何让工作变得有意义》。如果你不是订阅者，现在是查看“隐藏大脑Plus”的好时机。整个九月份，在苹果播客上订阅的听众将获得长达30天的免费试用。要获得30天的试用期，请在苹果播客上找到“隐藏大脑”并点击免费试用按钮，或者访问Apple.com斜杠Hidden Brain。
Your support helps us make research-based insights accessible, relevant, and engaging to a broad audience around the world. Again, that site is apple.com slash hidden brain. Jen, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much, Shanker. It was a true pleasure. Do you have followed up questions or stories that you'd like to share with Jennifer Toasty Karris? Have you found a calling that gets you up in the morning each day? Are you a skeptic of callings? Or do you have questions about how to make work more meaningful?
你的支持帮助我们让基于研究的见解对世界各地的广大受众来说是易于理解的、相关的和引人入胜的。再次说明，网址是apple.com斜杠hidden brain。詹姆，非常感谢你今天加入“隐藏大脑”。非常感谢你，尚卡尔。这真是莫大的荣幸。你是否有后续问题或故事想与詹妮弗·托斯蒂·卡里斯分享？你是否找到了每天早晨叫醒你的天职？你对天职持怀疑态度吗？或者你对如何让工作更有意义有什么疑问？
If you'd be willing to share your questions, stories, and comments with the Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, calling. That email address again is Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org. I'd like to call out some unsung heroes on this 10th anniversary show. Kara McGurk Allison played a central role in getting the show started and Maggie Penman was one of our first producers. Jenna Weiss-Burman helped build several pilot episodes.
如果你愿意与“隐藏大脑”的听众分享你的问题、故事和评论，请在手机上录制语音备忘录并通过电子邮件发送给我们，邮箱是Ideas在Hiddenbrain.org。请使用主题行：天职。再次重复该电子邮件地址是Ideas在Hiddenbrain.org。在这个十周年节目中，我想感谢一些无名英雄。卡拉·麦格克·艾利森在节目的创立中发挥了核心作用，玛吉·佩曼是我们的首批制作人之一。珍娜·韦斯·伯曼帮助构建了几个试播集。
Lots of others helped as well. Lynette Clemitson and Anya Grunman provided a lot of guidance, and Lauren Embry, Paul Haga, Paul Ginsberg and Camilla Smith provided some of the initial seed funding. We're so grateful to all of them. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz,
还有许多其他人也提供了帮助。莱内特·克莱米森和阿尼亚·格伦曼提供了很多指导，劳伦·埃姆里、保罗·哈加、保罗·金斯伯格和卡米拉·史密斯提供了一些最初的种子资金。我们非常感谢他们所有人。“隐藏大脑”由“隐藏大脑传媒”制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·帕尔、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·克雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、
Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Next week on the show, we're going to kick off a new series. It's a topic that almost everyone cares about, a topic that has inspired great songs and poems, and works of fiction. That topic is love.
奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德维克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制作人。我是“隐藏大脑”的执行主编。下周的节目中，我们将开启一个新的系列。这是一个几乎每个人都关心的主题，一个激发了伟大歌曲、诗歌和小说创作的主题。这个主题就是爱。
Over the next few weeks, we'll talk about what happens when the heady first phase of infatuation is done and the harder work of navigating the day-to-day with your partner begins. So, oh, we're having a good time, we're feeling jokey with each other, and something happened.
在接下来的几周里，我们将讨论当头脑发热的迷恋初期结束，与伴侣共同应对日常生活这一更艰巨的工作开始时会发生什么。所以，哦，我们玩得很开心，我们感觉彼此之间在开玩笑，然后发生了一些事情。
But maybe I can just, like, keep going with the playfulness, and it'll just wash away. And, you know, just as it turns out, it doesn't usually work. That's Love 2.0 starting next week. I hope you'll join us. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但也许我可以，你知道的，继续保持这种开玩趣的态度，它就会烟消云散。而且，你知道的，事实证明，这通常不管用。这就是下周开始的《爱 2.0》。我希望你能加入我们。我是尚卡尔·韦达当姆。再见。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。